êtes avec nous vous vous avez participé
à quelle émission avec Stéphan Plazza
moi j'ai fait les plusieurs émissions
sur recherche appartenant chasseur
d'appart d'accord vous faites quoi vous
agent immobilier ah très bienacc normal
22 ans donc tout jusqu'ici tout vous
avez 22 ans 22 ans de profession ah
d'accord ben faites ce que vous voulez
he et ça s'est bien passé avec lui très
bien non toujours toujours dans son
humour des blagues du matin au soir
vraiment très bonne ambiance voilà parce
que c'est c'est quoi parce que là il
était comment il vous a dragué il était
dragué dans la rigolade quoi moi j'ai
fait avec lui m'a dragué Stéphan mais
c'est vrai il était dans l'humour du
matin au soir donc il se prenait pas au
sérieux il était fidèle à son personnage
que ce soit en dehors ou ou dans devant
les caméras enfin il y avait pas de pas
de faux semblant quoi c'était vraiment
quelqu'un d'agréable et d'ambiance sur
le plateau on a pu lire beaucoup
d'articles déclarant que Stéphane était
compliqué sur les plateaux enfin c'est
en juste un article de Libération
d'ailleurs où je vous ai parlé hier où
il disait ouais Stéphan Plaz j'aiiré
j'ai deviré un peu menaçant
fa des blagues sexuell ouais mais bon
oui alors ouais des blagues un peu
lourdes ça peut nous aussi on en fait on
est d'accord non mais ça va un petit peu
quand
même non mais clairement c'était
enfantin et c'était il y avait rien de
non mais c'est ça ouais il y a rien de
il y a rien alors elle revient donc l'ex
compagne de Stéphan Plaza également sur
les différentes rumeurs d'infidélité et
d'alcoolisme euh après sur sa fidélité
je ne suis pas sûr que que ce soit
quelqu'un d'extrêmement fidèle ils sonit
jamais cachés mais après j'ai problèmes
d'alcool cas la laqu il il étaient pas
alcoolique en je ne pense pas mais non
enfin moi je je suis très surprise aussi
d'entend ça moi je parle de la parf la
que j'ai avec lui hein ça a été 89 mois
euh quis ça une jolie période auquel n
Il nétait pas alcolique jamais sur moi
on a Faé des bon ensemble et et et ouais
alors euh on voit là et puis vous allez
voir il y a un autre extrait où elle
parle qu'elle a été contactée pour faire
tomber la animateur on va on va
l'écouter dans un instant mais angélique
vous vous avez participé à cette
émission pourqui on vous a invité aussi
c'est que cette émission c'est vrai
qu'elle avait été beaucoup beaucoup
commenter voilà avec Stéphan on a on a
deux extraits de ce prime à l'école à
l'époque il y avait eu beaucoup de voilà
de de de fans sur enfin de voilà de de
débat vous attituz sur votre physique et
sur celui des des candidates
regardez pardon les garçons c'est
dégueulasse c'est quand même autre chose
que
[Musique]
vous donc on a Emmanuel et éclair
éclair alors donc c'est vrai que voilà
il y avait cette extr qui avait fait
énormément parler et il y avait
également eu un commentaire de Stéphane
où il y avait eu des réactions sur les
réseaux
sociauxas la copine prof de sport c'est
énorme j'adore moi je la même copine
s'il te plaît tu ve la même et ben moi
je vais être ton voisin d'en face et je
vais même aller plus loin je pense que
les voisins d'en face devrait te payer
ton appartement pour avoir le privilège
de te voir faire du sport et peut-être
même sortir de la douche pardon non non
c'est nul ouis ça va il y a rienour lour
c'est nul estce que ça choque quelqu'un
Delphine Delphine c'est lourd mais je
suis choquée en fait j'ai même pas de
mot alors autant j'aime beaucoup le
j'aime beaucoup Stéphan Plazza et mais
mais ça c'est nul j'aime pas je alors
déjà dans le premier extrait pardon il
dit rien donc cet accè de sexiste il dit
rien juste une musique parce que les
filles sont des jolies filles on a quand
même encore le droit de le dire si ça
avait été une femme qui avait dit je
regarde un homme de par ma fenêtre parce
qu'il est beau et parce qu'il me plaît
physiquement on aurait rien dit bah
ouiche c'est bon moi je savoir comment
vous vous l'avez ressenti bah oui de la
même façon c'està-dire que pour moi ça
me choque pas par contre c'est lourd
c'est très lourd Ding mais ça vous a pas
gêné pour tournage ça vous a pas
pesé AG c'est pas une agression ouais
okleour ok donc ou donc pour vous pour
vous ouis quand vous voyez tout ce tout
là là là tout ce qui se passe autour de
de Stéphan vous êtes étonné ou vous
dites c'est bah oui enfin sur l'aspect
parce que c'est quand même quelqu'un
d'en jouer toujours en train d'essayer
de mettre de l'humour partout donc
forcément après on le connaît pas enfin
moi je le connais à travers l'aspect
professionnel et les émissions donc vous
êtes resté en contact avec lui oui ou ou
on ouais on est resté potte on s'est
revu de temps en temps Paris sur des
resto avec avec des tournages différents
des choses comme ça mais on est resté
potes ah voilà en je l'ai pas vu depuis
un moment mais ouis oui myiam non en
fait aussi dans cette émission ce qui
avait pas pas plu à l'époque c'est qu'
avait une voix off qui disait je crois
oh là là elle s'y connaît angélique en
volume il avec gros plans sur votre
poitrine d'ailleurs même le le CSA en
Belgique avait avait fait une alerte
quand l'émission avait été diffusée
là-bas donc c' des des desé ouais
c'était inapproprié BL voilà qui qui
était un peu jugé sexy c'est la voix off
c'était la voix off qui a été presque
plus appuyé en fait inapproprié
complètement sur St ver je voulais juste
donner une info selon nos sources Plazza
va porter plainte en diffamation contre
miaapart d'accord oui qui avait sorti
l'affaire récemment donc voilà ça se
prépare et puis peut-être comme on parle
beaucoup de l'affaire la plainte
l'enquête la police peut-être donner un
mot des avocats Stéphan Plazza son
avocate voilà qui estime que donc ces
femmes réagissent après avoir eu
connaissance de la plainte antérieure de
Stéphane Plazza vous vous souvenez que
lui-même avait porté al alors côté ça
sur qui sur une des je en juin dernier
voilà tectateur porter plainte contre
ces personnes pour une de ces personnes
contre l'une voilà pour cyber
harcèlement et
harcèlement cycement cy harcèlement
voilà etement AC du beur voilà et donc
ces avocats estiment que ces femmes
réagissent et leur diagnostic c'est que
ces femmes veulent faire payer coûte que
coûte une infidélité par vengeance
organisé dénigratoire et vexatoire donc
c'est quoi donc c'est quoi donc selon
les avocats de Stéphan Plazza c'est une
sorte quand vous dites qu'il était
harcelé il y avait du cyber harcèlement
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en fait et
bien il estime que c'était ourdi
c'est-à-dire que il y a eu effectivement
ce que disait myiam une réunion une
préparation de ces femmes pour le
dénigrer voilà pour le dénigrer pour
l'attaquer exactement et c'est la
contreattaque de ceses avocat ce qu'on
apprend aussi dans parage c'est que que
à chaque fois que que c'est ces femmes
enfin que Stéphane Plaza s'affichait sur
Instagram avec une femme elle lui
envoyait des messages d'insulte et
Karine l mararchand dit même que
Stéphane Plata lui aurait dit qu'il
avait la trouille que ses filles
allaient lui lui porter préjudice et
qu'elle allait se mettre ensemble en
fait pour lui nuire alors on va écouter
enfin cette jeune fille qu'on a eu elle
révèle avoir été contactée par des
femmes pour faire tomber
l'animateur moi-même sur les réseaux
sociaux j'ai j'ai été approché par par
certaines des jeunes femmes qui portent
des accusations très graves au jour
d'aujourd'hui et qui m' beaucoup beau
coup harcelé sur les réseaux et auok
j'ai mis un terme peine de porter plin
parce que je ne voulais pas me lger à
leur cause un petit peucharement mais
mais je je suis jamais rentré làdedans
il avait quandême une petite rencur de
chacune après je pas la relation qu'
mais mais oui on sentait quand même une
certaine ligue le qui se construit et
et je trouve ça pas très sympa voilà
donc c'est vrai que voilà donc c'est ces
deux euh témoignages ouis deux version
ouais c'estes deux témoignages qu'on a
de angélique et et de cette jeune fille
sont
assez pratiquement les mêmes donc c'est
ça c'est des blagues des trucs mais bon
voilà aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui va se
passer donc alors bah là l'enquête
l'enquête continue il y a des
expertises psychologiques qui vont être
faites par les les unités médicaux
judiciaires il y a d'autres témoins qui
vont être encore entendus par le juge
d'instruction et puis en fonction de ça
on verra si il y a procès ou si ça se
traduit en comment on dit s'il un non
lieu s'il y a un non lieu pour l'
faire alors angélique dou vous c'est
c'est quoi qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
dire vous pouvez dire vous vous avez pas
vous avez passé un bon moment avec lui
c'est OUI à chaque fois je vous dis
c'était très toujours dans la blague
toujours enfantin il cherchait à mettre
à l'aise c'était lourd mais c'était tout
son personnage en fait c'est l'adresse
que ce soit sur ces blagues ou euh ça
faisait ça faisait son charme c'est ça
ce qui ce qui est embêtant c'est aussi
par rapport aux agences aux agences
immobilières de Stéphane tada parce que
tout ça fait effectivement de la très
mauvaise pub puisque ce leur leur tout
le succès de ces ces agences sont sur
l'image de de l'animateur donc forcément
c'est c'est vraiment de la mauvaise F il
y a même des des agences voilà qui ont
été
vandalisé donc les les les les les les
comment les responsables des agences
sont très très inquiets puis comme en
plus le marché de l'immobilier ne
fonctionne pas hyper bien imobilière Act
non non mais en plus certains agents
immobiliers ont demandé à Stéphan Plazza
de faire baisser les royalties qui qui
lui donne et il a d'ailleurs refusé Gill
verdou c'est très important pour M6 he
puisque M6 a 51 % de tout le réseau
immobilier die bénisse et lui a encore
25,5 % je crois effectivement là
certains franchisés commencent à
manifester leur mécontentement je vous
donne un chiffre en recette publicitaire
c'est 30 millions net en 2023 Stéphan
plazard pour M6 en recette publicitaire
donc c'est quand même énorme voilà et le
réauchelle c'est beaucoup mais bon ça va
c'est c'est bien le réauz 8% 8% et le
réseau immobilier lupp rapporte à M6
12,3 million
divid c'est capital non je trouve que
moi j'avais jamais vu les photos qui ont
été diffusé là derrière vous tout à
l'heure je trouve que avant même que la
justice se prononce alors qu'on est en
pleine enquête encore une fois voir que
on puisse assimiler Stéphane Plaza à un
horrible bonhomme alors qu'on n'en sait
rien et qu'on est au milieu de l'enquête
je trouve ça terrible quoi encore une
fois c'est cette justice extrêmement
expéditive qui vient du peuple où on va
taguer des euh euh des des agences
immobilières oou on va essayer de le
faire passer peut-être pour quelqu'un
euh qui n'est pas lui en fait et encore
une fois oui mais en fait on est au
milieu du Guay c'est pour ça que j'ai
vraiment pris le soin de dire et et
c'est c'est comme tu l'as dit cy hier on
doit d'abord croire évidemment la parole
des victimes s'agit pas de ça mais de là
à en faire une justice immédiate
médiatique je sais bien que c'est
quelque chose qui est déjà dit mais
c'est insupportable enfin je veux dire
moi je je regarde beaucoup ces émissions
bon alors je suis peut-être pas le le le
le bon baromètre mais honnêtement j'ai
j'ai alors j'entends ce que vous avez
dit hein et ce côté gravele qui est pas
heureux mais de là en faire un horrible
personnage et à le jeter tout de suite
dans la case des des des des agresseurs
sexuels bah attendons quoi attendons de
voir la justice et puis condamons gens
sil plît parce que j'ai ce soir qui